this is obviously a survival story if he
doesn't get off the planet he's going to
die and yet he is optimistic he's funny
he doesn't take himself or a situation
that seriously so in making the movie
those are three kind of almost competing
ideas it's the script was like a full a
beautiful fall air cake with cherries
and cream on top because it had every
everything in there that you'd want to
make a good movie and it had the obvious
entities of the possibility of great
beauty and being Mars the bigger the
beautiful monster it had a great
possibility of all the great characters
and the leading man who stuck by himself
great action etc etc but actually what
surfaced as you're reading it was right
in there somewhere had big heart and it
the heart starts with Mark Watney who
demonstrates and I'm going to quote the
type of a film was made here almost 25
years ago very good drunk all the right
stuff the right serves fundamentally is
courage under fire courage under
pressure courage in peril and it's a bit
like being the first down this principal
photography right he woke on that that's
funny it's a joke okay he lays the
ground the the plan out because he can
only demonstrate courage and courage
will get him through and he as he says
at the end of the film I'll take one
step at a time and gradually I realize I
have a plan and then I have optimism and
then by God I may make it and I think
that's what evolves into his then
communicating by using an old
broken-down asset that he finds the
desert 13 days away and communicates
with with Mother Earth so from that
moment on everybody is helping everybody
which i think is a very good lesson for
today and it's not cute it's it should
be what we do and I think even
encouraging the Chinese to come into
this was a very healthy thing to do
rather than a cynical thing to do you
make a very specific choice in
production design wardrobe
that this is not in the distant future
there know hovercrafts back on earth
people are wearing suits and ties just
like they wear today and the book i
think is in many ways similar to that
that it's not in the distant future but
it's really in the hair now how
important was that as a storyteller to
make sure that was grounded in a
physical reality that we recognize that
it wasn't an alien world I mean I
thought it was crucial and as you say
there's no hovercrafts there's no the
only difference is that we've been to
Mars like it was important that we
related to it because the whole point is
it it's us it's it's about scientists
it's not really about anything other
than that Harry when you come on board I
suspect you already know you're going to
be working with some disco music in the
background which is a little bit of a
workaround but you've worked with Ridley
before we talked about the kind of the
stakes of this movie they're incredibly
perilous and yet the film is also
optimistic as a composer what does that
present to you in terms of how you're
going to go about capturing the tone
reflecting the tone of the story that
drew and Ridley are laying out in front
of you well it's not just optimistic but
it's quite humorous as well isn't it so
so the music just needed to / along and
support his character to begin with and
then blossom and hopefully add to the
tribe for the situation at the end of
the movie but you know the geographical
situation the movie was was quite tasty
for me as well I sense you know we're on
Mars and Mars movies before you don't
know what the local instruments are
there you know you mentioned the disco
music it was when I read the script
which Ridley sent to me after we we did
exodus last summer I got a personal note
saying read it like it do it
huh there was no sort of option in there
huh so drew can you move but I like to
see him when I'm talking about him yeah
so so yet the disco songs were there to
my knowledge what hey you'll know
because he wrote it but the in the in
the script it said song happened I mean
the songs were there in the script I
don't recall the name that they didn't
name the songs did it did how did um so
I mean you know I changin I'd little to
do with that but and in fact they when I
came on board so in post-production
there were several songs there and they
kind of stayed where they were in a one
notable exception which you know we
experimented with one part part of the
movie having a song there and how
everybody felt about that that was
actually a major moment of Watney
crossing Mars got you know making his
journey across Mars and you know it kind
of worked on a few level student at red
we had a song in there and then you know
really someone one day was in my studio
said look H you've got to you know do a
score q that and you know let's see what
happens if you do and so I did it and he
didn't hate it that high praise from
Ridley in their net so you know that's
other than that those songs were
embedded in the film but we also he
required and the choir at some point
almost suggests a requiem and yet it
also suggests the Hallelujah Chorus that
they are both kind of celebrating and
also kind of a little I think really
don't it because it's it's it for me
that the humanity of the movie was
something that Sean right through and
and you know I needed to find something
for the quarter sing I did you know
choirs a really good at singing Latin
but you know often that text would be
taken from the creed or some religious
leo you know that's something so it
didn't seem appropriate to label that
but it the spirituality of this
situation was good so i found a Russian
philosopher who lived before Christ and
he talked to it in Iran on the nature of
things that he talked about in his poem
um you know that the wonder of the
infinity of space and and all these good
things so that's what they that's what
the choir singing in Latin
to me that they kind of a bit like the
Greek chorus they were kind of us on
earth saying can't we can get it more
get it yeah the they were just
commenting on the situation then you
work closely with JPL and NASA and
obviously that gives you some
verisimilitude that was probably
important but I want talk about the
people that you worked with in the
character of scientists that work at JPL
and NASA and what they meant to you drew
and Ridley in terms of how you approach
this story their spirit their intellect
their passion and how that reflected in
the movie that you ultimately ended up
making when I was sort of toying with
the idea of doing this when I was pacing
around the house thinking about the book
I found it was haunting me and my wife I
was talking my life about it and she
said well what's it about and I said
well it's about a guy who get stranded
on Mars but what it's really about is a
bunch of scientists and she said oh you
mean like your hometown and I at this
light bulb went off in my head because I
grew up in Los Alamos New Mexico which
is just a town of rocket scientists
that's all it is and it's very strange
town and I realized that's what I love
so much about Andy's book it's that he
captured this thing that I hadn't seen
captured before which is the way
scientists talk the sort of camaraderie
and the humor and the sort of the humor
in the face of failure because science
is really about failure it's about you
screw up and then you try again and then
you screw up and then you try again and
and and and because of that it sort of
generates this deadpan sense of humor
that I see happen over and over with
scientists and to me that was everything
to me that was like that's that's the
soul of our book is that you have the
movie it's like it's the metaphor for
life you it's all about [ __ ] up over
and over and then try to get somewhere
and and so when when it came down you
know time we we went to JPL talk to NASA
and you'd see the same thing they all
had the same far side calendars on their
desk they all the same that's all the
same you know scientific progress like
that and really captured it so
beautifully with between them it so it's
about the camaraderie ready is that what
you took away from that that the
camaraderie I mean what was your
impression I know I was actually in
Washington two nights ago and we run it
very beautiful theater National
Geographic actually looked as good as
this and in their work NASA the night
they shared the evening NASA and some JP
and National Geographic and the the boss
of NASA isn't it was an astronaut 30
years ago and the sedatives now
constantly pursuing hounding for more
and more funding was the astronaut
within 30 years ago and the other
astronaut was on stage sitting with me
has been up there six times the
International Space Station was about to
go up next week and it's all it's a job
but these guys are like savant very
mature genius children that enthusiasm
is unbelievable and they just love what
they do the woman next to me was
probably she weren't going to be I think
she look like 38 but actually yeah but
she was the senior scientist to who is
in charge of going to Mars and that's
and that's that plan they are assuming
they will be on Mars mid-2020s maybe
late 2020 37 38